jetzt kommen wir zu einem weiteren
tagesordnungspunkt an diesem donnerstag
hier im bundestag viele unternehmen und
auch bürger haben finanziell weiter auch
mit der korona krise zu kämpfen
schon während der
koalitionsverhandlungen hat die ampel
beschlossen dass viele hilfen verlängert
werden heute passiert das jetzt mit der
abschließenden lesung des vierten
coroner steuer hilfe gesetzes da fehlt
eine ganze menge darunter die home
office pauschale wird es auch für 2022
geben beispielsweise unternehmen dürfen
verluste besser verrechnen wir hören
dazu eine menge in der aussprache so
viele wirte sicher sein markus herbrand
für die fdp der erster redner jetzt
heute geht es etwas harmonisch dazu das
liegt mir auch persönlich ehrlich gesagt
viel mehr mit dem corolla steuer hilfe
gesetz hier setzen wir nämlich eine
ganze reihe von maßnahmen um
entlastungsmaßnahmen die auf der einen
seite sehr sozial ausgewogen aber auch
wirtschaftlich wirklich sehr sinnvoll
sind schon die korona steuergesetze 1
bis 3 die die vorgängerregierung auf den
weg gebracht hat wurde durch große teile
der opposition auch immer unterstützt
wenn ich jetzt mal von der temporären
umsatz steuersenkung absehe die wilma
sehr kritisch gesehen haben haben wir
diese corona steuer hilfe gesetze 1 bis
3 auch immer sehr
optimistisch unterstützt zum gesetz
selber will ich sagen es sind eine ganze
reihe von maßnahmen die schon im gesetz
standen auf der anderen seite aber auch
im gesetzgebungsverfahren durch die
ampel noch mal deutlich erweitert wurden
wir führen ein die steuerfreistellung
für einen corona bonus pflegekräfte im
gesetzgebungsverfahren haben wir diesen
personenkreis noch mal deutlich
ausgeweitet und wir sind uns der sache
bewusst das ist sehr schwierig in der
abgrenzung und wir haben uns da sehr
stark daran gehalten was im
infektionsschutzgesetz an personen
gruppen aufgelistet ist das ist eine
gute lösung und wir haben den
personenkreis so nochmal deutlich
erweitern können
darüber hinaus darüber hinaus verlängern
wir die steuerfreiheit für das
kurzarbeitergeld um weitere drei monate
und werden sehen müssen ob das
ausreichend ist wir verlängern auch die
home office pauschale bis zum 31.12 und
ja wir sind uns auch darüber einig in
der ampel da muss noch etwas mehr
geschehen wir waren wir haben den
experten da sehr sorgfältig auch
zugehört wir glauben wir brauchen da
eine etwas strukturelle lösung und
werden das in kürze angehen zunächst
einmal jetzt hier die verlängerung bis
zum 31 12 damit wir die
lebenswirklichkeit vieler menschen die
arbeitswirklichkeit vieler menschen
besser abbilden können wir haben die
degressive abschreibung noch mal
verlängert um ein weiteres jahr ein ganz
wichtiger investitionsanreiz für klar
vor allem klein- und mittelständische
unternehmen und wir verlängern die reden
willst du die investitions fristen für
rücklagen nach den paragraphen 6b und 7
g im einkommenssteuergesetz das ist ganz
wichtig für unternehmen die
möglicherweise jetzt nicht die
liquidität haben um diese rücklagen
auflösen oder in anspruch nehmen zu
können weil einfach jetzt krise war
deshalb kommt diese verlängerung genau
richtig und wir
packen noch mal den verlust die
verlustverrechnung an wir verlängern die
verlustverrechnung noch mal bis zum
31.12
2023 führen also die erhöhten
verlustverrechnung beträge zurück erst
im
veranlagungszeitraum
2024 und wir implementieren diesem
verlust rück trag dauerhaft auf zwei
jahren ja
das ist auch in der ampel durchaus
strittig gewesen das müssen wir sagen
wir haben da drüber länger diskutiert
und einige hätten sich mehr
vorstellen können letzten endes ist auf
diesen kompromiss hinausgelaufen denen
wir selbstverständlich auch mittragen
und wir sind auch noch mal an die
fristen für die steuerberatenden berufe
ram herangegangen und da sogar über die
vorstellung des bundesrates hinaus weil
die dass ein berufsstand ist der
wirklich mit ganz enormen belastungen in
dieser corona pandemie zu kämpfen hat
die korona hilfen 1 bis 4 müssen
abgerechnet werden jetzt kommen in
zukunft auch noch die die grundsteuer
belastung dazu deshalb machen wir es
möglich dass die fristen da auch
dauerhaft verlängert werden und wir
sorgen für planungssicherheit
planungssicherheit das ist zurückgeführt
wird dass diese dauerhaften
fristverlängerungen zurückgeführt werden
damit wir möglichst 20 25 wieder beim
normalzustand angelangt sind das ist
planungssicherheit für diese büros und
letzten endes vor allem für die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
und schließlich schaffen wir die
bilanzielle abzinsung von
unverzinslichen verbindlichkeiten ab
eine regelung ist aus meiner sicht nie
bedurft hätte und sowieso keine große
rolle spielt im steuerrecht es ist
sozusagen eine kleine hygiene maßnahmen
im steuerrecht die wir an dieses gesetz
noch an gekoppelt haben meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen bedanke mich
für die tolle zusammenarbeit in den
vielen gesprächen die wir in diesem zu
diesem gesetz geführt haben auch mit der
opposition in der tat ein wirklich gutes
und gelungenes gesetz ich bitte um
zustimmung herzlichen dank
er sagt markus herbrand für die fdp
fraktion
und heute ist nämlich zweite und dritte
lesung und entsprechend daneben auch die
abstimmung im anschluss an diese debatte
fritz künstler jetzt für die union frau
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen meine damen und herren
insbesondere auf den zuschauerrängen sie
nehmen harmonie war herr kollege hermann
hat dass ihr eingefordert und ich kann
vorab schon sagen das wusste er auch
nach den beratungen im ausschuss dass
wir diesen corona steuergesetz hier
zustimmen werden weil wir diese steuer
hilfe gesetz wir natürlich auch in einer
gewissen tradition der letzten drei
kronach steuer hilfe gesetze sehen die
wir in der großen koalition noch
gemeinsam meist auch mit der zustimmung
der fdp beschlossen haben sind im
wesentlichen die gleichen maßnahmen die
dort enthalten sind die jetzt entfristet
werden oder fortgeschrieben werden wir
bedauern aber um ein bisschen wasser in
den wein zu diesen dass es ein wenig
spät gekommen ist also der
regierungsentwurf war erst im februar 22
und muss jetzt sehen dinge die dieses
jahr komplett gelten sollen werden im
bundesrat im juni beschlossen also ein
halbes jahr ist vorbei bevor die
maßnahmen tatsächlich beschlossen wurden
und sie haben vorhin von
rechtssicherheit gesprochen die
geschaffen werden soll ist das etwas
schwierig wenn der beschluss im
bundesrat am 10 juni 2022 erst erfolg im
ergebnis habe ich gesagt stimmen wir zu
aber im ergebnis hätte so ein wenig mehr
sein können sie gehen in den richtigen
weg den richtigen weg sind aber leider
auf halber strecke wie so oft stehen
geblieben und wir hatten ihnen es so
leicht gemacht wir haben einen
entschließungsantrag eingebracht mit 14
punkten herr kollege hermann die ihnen
nicht ganz unbekannt vorkommen dürften
die sie hätten übernehmen können aber
leider werden sie ja wohl gemeinsam
heute als ampelkoalition wie schon im
ausschuss diesen antrag ablehnen unser
ziel ist gemeinsam wir wollen
wirtschaftliche folgen der korona krise
aber auch der ukraine krise abfedern und
so dazu beitragen dass stabilisierung
bei den unternehmen gibt aber auch
entlastungen bei arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer und es geht auch darum die
eigene thal basis bei unternehmen wieder
zu stärken die in der schwierigen zeit
ihr eigenkapital abschmelzen mussten das
unglück da war und dazu geführt hat dass
sie in der krise bestand hatten was aber
fehlt um das ganze vielleicht ein wenig
weiter auf in richtung vorgeformt
projekt zu bringen ich will ja gar nicht
das böse wort unternehmenssteuerreform
im mund nehmen wäre doch einiges mehr
notwendig gewesen und ist ja schon
spannend zu sehen wenn man die
mitteilung vom bundesfinanzminister
lindner ließ in seiner broschüre
finanzpolitik in der zeitenwende und er
davon spricht dass wir ein
wettbewerbsfähiges steuerrecht brauchen
und auch davon spricht dass die
belastungen der kapitalgesellschaften in
deutschland zu hoch ist hat er recht
aber wo sie bleiben die vorschläge frage
ich nur einrichtungen
bundesfinanzminister lindner und die
staatssekretärin ist ja da die kann das
ja dann mitnehmen also würden schon
erwarten dass man nicht nur papiere
schreibt sondern dass man auch handelt
und dinge hier ins parlament einbringen
und sie haben natürlich wichtige dinge
angesprochen adressiert in diesem kroner
steuer hilfe gesetzt und ich glaube ein
punkt ist die liquidität in den
unternehmen zu stärken bei liquidität
ist mit das wichtigste und darum
verstehen wir es gut dass sie die
verlustverrechnung dem verlust rücktritt
auf zwei jahre verlängert haben aber ich
muss ihnen ganz ehrlich sagen dagegen
noch mehr ich weiß auch dass wir diese
diskussion in der großen koalition in
der vergangenheit geführt haben und ich
weiß auch in richtung grüne und fdp wie
schwer es mit diesem koalitionspartner
über verlustverrechnung zu reden weil
das problem der sozialdemokratie in
deutschland ist anscheinend dass sie
immer eine verlustverrechnung wäre ein
steuergeschenk und da muss man der spd
nicht sagen da ihre zeit komplett weil
das sind latente
steuerlich qualitätsansprüche steuer
erstattungsansprüche von unternehmen die
sie wieder bekommen wenn sie mal
verluste gemacht haben und dann wieder
gewinne gemacht haben oder in der
vergangenheit gewinne gemacht haben
bekommen sie ihr geld nur wieder und sie
würden in dieser situation weil hat
besseren verlustverrechnung ihr geld
schneller wieder bekommen von daher wäre
es begrüssenswert gewesen den rückzug
auf drei jahre auszuweiten oder sogar
vier jahre auszuweiten wenn ich das hier
als hinweis der grünen aufnehmen darf
weil jetzt der zweijährige verlust sagt
der zum glück dauerhaft kommen aber in
die verlustjahre 20 21 und 20 22 geht
also von daher passt das nicht ganz auch
über die höhe haben wir schon viel
gestritten ich glaube dass es auch um zu
erreichen dass es sich unbedingt zu
erklären warum größere unternehmen ihre
verluste nicht verrechnen dürfen werden
kleinere unternehmen bis zehn millionen
das verrechnen können und ein weiterer
punkt ist die der verlustvortrag ich
verstehe gar nicht um das thema
überhaupt nicht aufgegriffen worden ist
es ist ja so in deutschland wenn sie
verluste gemacht haben können sie der
gewinne des zukunft nur teilweise
verrechnen und das ist doch eigentlich
das richtige unternehmen die aus der
krise herauskommen die dann wieder
gewinne macht dass man denen dann die
möglichkeit gibt das vollständig mit den
verlusten der vergangenheit zu
verrechnen das wäre glaube ich das
richtige signal gewesen
des weiteren geht es ums thema
abschreibungen herr kollege herr brandt
hat herausgestellt dass werden heute
läuft und die degressive abschreibung
ist entfristet worden aber warum mussten
sie den fristen weil die super
abschreibungen die sie im
koalitionsvertrag den menschen in diesem
land versprochen haben für das jahr 2022
und 20 23 bis jetzt nur auf dem papier
da ist es gibt keinen wurf es gibt keine
idee es gibt nur zwei zeilen im
koalitionsvertrag und da muss ich sagen
mit verlaub das ist ein bisschen wenig
und dann müssen sie sich nicht loben
lassen für die degressive abschreibung
und wenn wir ja erst dann sinnvoll
solche verbesserungen von
abschreibungsbedingungen nicht mitten im
jahr zu beschließen sondern rechtzeitig
im vorlauf zu beschließen weil
investitionszyklen bauunternehmen dauern
länger also von daher wäre es richtiger
gewesen dann auch das jahr 2023
mitzunehmen weil sie glauben ja selber
nicht mehr dass ihre super abschreibung
20 23 kommen wird also von daher ein
bisschen mehr mut wer hier nicht nur
mehr mut zu fortschritt sondern auch
mehr mut zu vernünftiger steuerpolitik
wer hier gut gewesen und
weitere dinge fehlen ich will nur das
thema ansprechen verluste in der
situation die jetzt entstehen
unternehmen die beteiligung in russland
haben das thema ist überhaupt nicht
adressiert sie haben es thema überhaupt
nicht aufgenommen das bedaure ich sehr
weil da gibt es erhebliche probleme
durch die sanktionen durch enteignungen
durch zerstörungen haben deutsche
unternehmen die beteiligung halten in
russland erhebliche probleme da wäre
auch mehr gewesen abschließen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich habe es
gesagt wir stimmt zu da war mehr luft
nach oben schade dass sie keine unserer
weiß richtenden vorschläge aus dem
entschließungsantrag übernommen haben
aber sie werden ja die möglichkeit haben
das im weiteren gesetzgebungsverfahren
zu tun und dann werden sie das als ihren
eigenen erfolg verbuchen aber ich werde
immer darauf hinweisen dass wir das
schon vorher gefordert herzlichen dank
künstler war das für die
unionsfraktionen also einige punkte hier
am gesetzentwurf der ampel da hat er
sich daran abgearbeitet die union hat
einen eigenen antrag vorgelegt und
fordert unter anderem dass der gesamte
einkommensteuertarif an die unerwartet
hohe inflation angepasst werden sollen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen meine
damen und herren der künstler wenn sie
uns immer so kritisieren aber am ende
dann doch zustimmen freut uns dass in
der tat sehr das vierte
keine noch was werden mit uns genau das
vierte corinna steuer hilfe gesetz ist
eine zentrale und wichtige maßnahme um
etwas zu bewegen für arbeitnehmerinnen
und arbeitnehmer in unserem land für das
thema arbeit und für die unterstützung
von kleinen und mittleren unternehmen in
einem durchaus sehr angespannten
wirtschaftlichen umfeld ein gutes werk
ist im rahmen unserer gemeinsamen
verhandlungen und beratungen noch besser
geworden unser gesetz steht in einer
guten tradition es wurde schon gesagt
bisheriger coroner gesetze nicht nur
wegen des konsenses sondern weil wir
hier erneut zu schnell greifende
maßnahmen zur hilfe und entlastung
kommen dort wo die folgen der pandemie
besonders spürbar sind in besonderer
weise gilt das natürlich für die
beschäftigten im gesundheitswesen und in
der pflege die von uns vorgelegte steuer
und auch abgabenfreiheit für die korona
sonderzahlung ist eine logische
konsequenz und zugleich wichtige
ergänzung des pflege bonus gesetzes bei
angestellten den krankenhäusern und in
der langzeitpflege in ambulanten und
stationären einrichtungen tätig sind wir
wollen mit der ermöglichung von
steuerfreien corona boni für eine
finanzielle wertschätzung insbesondere
der arbeit bei den beschäftigten sorgen
die viele überstunden zu bewältigung
dieser pandemie auf sich genommen haben
die erheblichen mentalen belastungen
ausgesetzt waren und natürlich auch
direkten
gesundheitsgefahren und stichwort halbe
strecke weil es unter anderem in der
öffentlichen anhörung auch weitergehende
forderungen gab weitere berufsgruppen
rhein zu nehmen will ich noch mal
ausdrücklich sagen es ist aus unserer
sicht absolut vertretbar und gut dort zu
helfen wo die folgen der pandemie mit am
stärksten ausgeprägt waren und das sind
die bereiche gesundheit und pflege und
dazu stehen wir liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
es ist ein schöner erfolg der
verhandlungen und berichterstatter
gespräche dass wir jetzt ampel den
adressatenkreis für den steuerfreien
corona bonus erhöht haben in dem jetzt
analog zum bundesrat die tarifverträge
mit reinnehmen die freiwilligen zahlung
und auch aufstockung durch die
arbeitgeber und es wurde ja schon von
den herbrand genannt weitere
einrichtungen gemäß des
infektionsschutzgesetzes arztpraxen
dialyse reha und ambulantes operieren
das bedeutet auf den punkt gebracht bis
zu eine million beschäftigte mehr
nämlich 870.000 medizinische
fachangestellte und 86.000
rettungssanitäterin rettungssanitäter
können zusätzlich von unserem gesetz
profitieren und wir sind uns auch sicher
dass die arbeitgeber von dieser
möglichkeit rege gebrauch machen werden
das ist ein ganz wichtiges signal in die
gesellschaft hinein und echter
fortschritt durch eine fortschritts
koalition liebe kollegen hinkriegen
wichtig für die stützung der konjunktur
in der aktuellen lage und für die
liquidität und investitionsfähigkeit
gerade von kleinen und mittleren
unternehmen sind die maßnahmen die wir
auf den weg bringen die degressive
abschreibung die bis dem
koalitionsvertrag so vorgesehen war aber
jetzt natürlich auch sehr notwendig ist
im vorgriff auf die sich in konzeption
befindliche
investitionspläne die verlängerung der
investitions fristen für reinvestitionen
und die verlängerung der erweiterten
verlustrechnung und vor allem die jetzt
neu auf dauer angelegte möglichkeit des
verlusts zurücktrat auf zwei jahre das
ist eine wirkliche weiterentwicklung
unseres steuerrechts wir bewegen uns
damit auch in der internationalen
dynamik von steuerpolitischen maßnahmen
für unternehmen
das ist gut für unsere volkswirtschaft
und das ist auch gut für den standort
deutschland liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
was bleibt ist die botschaft die ampel
koalition handelt in ungemütlichen
zeiten wir helfen beschäftigten im
gesundheitswesen in der pflege wir
helfen dem mittelstand und bringen das
thema arbeit voran in diesem sinne
werden wir aus überzeugung den vierten
corner steuer hilfe gesetz zustimmen
ohne so schön dass es auch andere
überzeugt vielen dank
[Applaus]
das wort hat der abgeordnete albrecht
glaser für die auch
[Applaus]
präsidentin meine damen und herren der
gesetzentwurf zielt darauf ab das
steuerrecht als wichtiges instrument zur
stabilisierung stärkung der konjunktur
einzusetzen wie es in der begründung
heißt um die wirtschaftlichen folgen der
pandemie abzumildern die vorredner haben
die einzelmaßnahmen bereits aufgezählt
degressive afa verlust rückt
steuerfreiheit ist ferienwohnungs der
jungprofis pauschale und viele andere
dinge mehr die gleiche richtung zielt
ein änderungsantrag der cdu csu fraktion
mit zahlreichen forderungen die in den
letzten zwei jahren schon mehrfach von
der fdp-fraktion im bundestag beantragt
wurden bis 20 bis 20 20 in diesem hause
üblich auch von der cdu wurden die alle
reflex schafft abgelehnt in dieser zeit
politische agonie fällt auch die
unsinnige wiederbelebung der grundsteuer
das war steuerliche denkmalspflege das
gegenteil vom fortschritt in diesen
tagen bekommen die eigentümer von 35
millionen grundstücken papierberge um
ihre immobilienwerte zu einem eine
drehende von unserem zusatzpunkt 1
beantragte fristverlängerung für die
bewältigung dieses bürokratiemonster das
ist daher geboten
bereits in der kirche oft in kirchhofs
echter steuerreform von vor zehn jahren
kommt die grundsteuer nicht mehr vor und
in jedem kopf eines steuerreform kommt
sie auch nicht mehr vor in der
begründung dass sie die ohren das heißt
es weiter dass die anhaltend hohe
inflation das niedrige
wirtschaftswachstum anzeichen einer
stagnation sein könnten meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren das ist in
der tat stand der erkenntnis die
inflationsrate lag im april dieses
jahres bei 7,4
energiekosten sind um 35 im
jahresvergleich gestiegen erdgas hat mit
47,5 zum preis schon beigetragen
98,6 das gespenst der inflation in der
eu kommt also mit macht was zu erwarten
war jahrelang wohnungs erzählen dass die
inflation besiegt sei dann war die
inflation von unter aber nahe 2 eine
neue preisstabilität eine eigene
definition des hauses ezb als ich die
inflationsraten über 2 prozent die
bewegte wurde das nachher tief des
symmetrischen
inflationsziels bemüht um auch diesen
vorgang irgendwie wegzureden die ezb
verlautbaren in diesen tagen zieht ihre
wird glauben dass die inflation im laufe
dieses jahres zurückgehen und im
nächsten und übernächsten jahr viel
niedriger sein wird wie in diesem jahr
zitat ende wie kann man sich dieses
ausmaß an realitätsverweigerung erklären
gerade hat die us-notenbank die zinsen
zur inflationsbekämpfung erhöhen müssen
die ezb betreibt stattdessen
auftragsarbeit für den klub mit der
romanischen staaten der seit jahren den
ezb-rat beherrscht von unabhängigkeit
der ezb kein
frau lagarde ist und war französische
politikerin meine damen und herren von
wirtschaft versteht sie nebenbei bemerkt
auch nichts
dass alle die interesse dieser mehrheit
und ihrer präsidentin ist die
überschuldeten romanische länder vor
staatskonkurses zu bewahren werden die
euro zinsen angehoben steigen die kosten
für die staatsschulden bleibt die
inflation oder wird sie größer
schnellsten die staatsschulden das ist
die handlungs leitende maxime von
lagarde und ihren klub ein deutschen
bank gewann er hat dort keine chancen
wohl deshalb hat er resigniert seinen
hut genommen wie zwei deutsche
chefvolkswirte ebenfalls kurz vorher
der bestand an zentral agent meine damen
und herren hat sich seit 2008 bis ende
letzten jahres von 880 milliarden auf 6
billionen erhöht das ist eine
versiegelung der geldmenge in der
gleichen zeit ist das bip in der
eurozone um 32 prozent gestiegen dh der
geldmenge von 600 prozent erhöhung steht
eine inflation entsteht eine
wirtschaftswachstum von 32 gegenüber ein
vorgang der bei der wirklich
unabhängigen bundesbank unvorstellbar
wäre die finanzierung des
staatshaushaltes durch die notenpresse
und abgekoppelt von der realen
güterproduktion hat in der geschichte
der menschheit immer zu staatskrisen
geführt die null negativ
zinspolitik verstärkt seit jahren den
effekt dieses losen schuldenpolitik die
ezb die staatsschulden exzesse der
mitgliedstaaten größtenteils
mitfinanziert und dadurch erst
ermöglicht die staatsschulden der
euro-länder sind seine finanzkrise von
6,7 billionen auf 11,3 millionen
angewachsen mehr als 200 mal wurden
dabei die stabilitätskriterien gerissen
natürlich ohne sensoren von diesem
schuldenzuwachs der diese inflation
produziert an der sie herumdoktern um
4,6 millionen hat alleine die ezb 76
prozent durch aufkauf von staatsanleihen
in die eigenen bücher genommen damit hat
sie gegen das ausdrückliche verbot der
staatsfinanzierung nach artikel 23 amv
in eklatanter weise verstoßen der bgh
sieht das natürlich alles anders weil
dort die richtermehrheit die gleiche ist
wie die im ezb rat und in der kommission
die eu kommission flankiert den schulden
wahnsinn durch zusätzliche ebenso wenig
als
eigenwillige eigene verschuldung in höhe
von 828 milliarden sogenannte resilienz
maßnahmen für über schulden des staates
wozu das alles ein auseinanderbrechen
des regimes soll um jeden preis
verhindert werden wollte war text wer
diese union in einem großstadt
verwandten will wie es der
koalitionsvertrag vorsieht der muss
viele nationale demokratien zerstören
die geeignet wären eine solche
entwicklung zu verhindern und sie will
und wird erzeugen ein unregierbar es
etwas was an die stelle von
nationalstaaten die demokratien sein
können und nur die können demokratien
seien setzen und das genau ist das
ergebnis das ich jetzt in der konferenz
der eu haben mit gezinkten teilnehmern
800 555
555 100 sich millionen einwohnern das
muss eine repräsentative
meinungsfreiheit
von dieser regierung gemacht wird durch
placebos bei energiekosten kurzzeitige
entlastung von energie steuern und eben
auch verspätete verbesserung von
steuereinnahmen für unternehmen ist der
versuch das eu und ezb versagen national
zu reparieren meine sehr verehrten damen
das wird nicht gelingen die eu staaten
befinden sich in einem dilemma entweder
wird die inflation zu einem massiven
kaufkraft und der bevölkerung zu
massenentlassungen von sparern führen
oder wir werden erneut staatsschulden
erschließen erleben die nicht
beherrschbar sind ich komme zum ende
frau präsidentin das alles wird die
existenz des euro fiel frage stellen ob
ihnen das gefällt oder nicht zum
vorgelegten gesetzentwurf werden wir
unsere enthalten so cdu-antrag werden
wir zustimmen aber beides meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren wird die
großwetterlage die ihm geschildert habe
nicht verändern
wenn
[Applaus]
herr staatsminister der staatsminister
ade machen sie sich keine sorgen meine
sexuelle orientierung wechsel stündlich
der bundestags- vizepräsident wolfgang
kubicki hier nämlich während der rede
von albrecht glaser gab es einen wechsel
im präsidium und wolfgang kubicki hat
petra pau abgelöst
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine
lieben kolleginnen und kollegen auch
liebe bürgerinnen und bürgern die
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
heute ist ein guter tag für unternehmen
und für sehr sehr viele beschäftigte und
auch für sehr sehr viele geschäft
beschäftigte im gesundheitsbereich
hinter geben gesetzes nahmen 40 corona
steuer hilfe gesetz verbergen sich
ziemlich viele echt tolle dinge für
unternehmen beispielsweise dass endlich
die verlustverrechnung und zwar nicht
nur temporär sondern dauerhaft auf zwei
jahre ausgedehnt wird das wird uns für
zukünftige krisen fit machen und lieber
herr künstler ja man hätte auf
rückwirkend noch mehr machen können aber
das ist eine wertvolle entscheidung mit
der wir uns zukunftsfest aufstellen und
deswegen finde ich die großartig
außerdem
verlängern wir und davon profitieren
auch kleine und mittelständische
unternehmen ganz besonders nochmal die
investitions fristen denn lieferketten
sind gerade wirklich schwierig das
wissen wir alle und durch diese
verlängerung kann man da auch noch mal
besser von profitieren und den
unternehmen in diesen schwierigen zeiten
helfen zum home office hatte der kollege
herr brand schon gesagt es geht darum
jetzt einmal kurzfristig und dieses
gesetz ist ja eine kombination aus
schnellem und pragmatischem handeln aber
auch zukunftsgerichtete themen zu
adressieren und beim home das ist es so
dass verlängern wir jetzt einmal die
kaschemme um jahr aber und dass wir bei
dieser prozess auch sehr gut wir haben
uns darauf geeinigt zu schauen auch im
sinne des arbeitszeiten arbeitszimmer
der ganzen themen die wir noch
beschäftigen wollen was heißt arbeiten
im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
eigentlich und dann nochmal zu guten aus
steuerlichen gesetzgebungen zu kommen
damit wissen anfang gelegt und das
werden wir noch weiter machen
ein ganz besonderes herzensanliegen ist
mir aber heute nochmal zu betonen was
wir im parlament gemeinsam noch
hinbekommen haben und zwar ziehe ich
mich da ganz ganz besonders darauf dass
wir noch einmal deutlich ausgeweitet
haben wer von der steuerfreiheit
profitieren dass ein pflege bonus aber
eben auf anderen boni so viele menschen
im gesundheitswesen haben
unermessliches geleistet und da können
wir nicht nur auf dem krankenhaus
tätigen oder in der langzeitpflege
tätigen sondern wir haben es im
parlament geschafft als
finanzpolitikerin und auch als
gesundheitspolitikerin zu schauen dass
auch die fast eine million medizinischen
fachangestellten die vielen im
rettungsdienst tätigen personen dass
auch diese zumindest mit einer
steuerfreiheit von einem bonus eine
gewisse finanzielle wertschätzung auch
mal haben und das ist großartig und
darüber freue ich mich ganz persönlich
ganz besonders
nochmals im detail ist es eben nicht nur
für tarifliche boni auch für freiwillig
gezahlte und ebenso einen sehr sehr
großen personenkreis
und dann es fühlt sich vielleicht erst
mal kommen roding her wieder technische
an aber die steuer beratungsfristen
kleinere mittelständische unternehmen
auch größere unternehmen die korona
hilfen bekommen haben wissen wie
unfassbar aufwendig das auch ist jetzt
in den steuererklärungen das alles
nochmal aktuell kann die
überbrückungshilfe wir hatten und die
steuerkanzleien sie sich damit
beschäftigt haben die über 50.000 und
die hunderttausenden menschen die in
steuerkanzleien arbeiten die haben eine
riesige last da gerade vor sich und da
haben wir jetzt vorausschauend über sehr
viele jahre ein gutes abschmelzen das
modell geschaffen was sogar über den
gesetzentwurf noch hinausgeht und da
sind glaube ich gerade alle ich höre in
die szene hinein wirklich dankbar und
froh darüber dass wir da das gemacht
haben und sozialer ist es auch noch denn
anders als die vorgängerregierung
ermöglichen wir auch menschen die gar
nicht beratungspflicht ich sind endlich
auch ein bisschen mehr fristen zu haben
ein bisschen mehr entlastungen denn
jetzt nach dem chor ohne einschränkungen
diesem sommer möchte man vielleicht auch
lieber mal rausgehen als sich
hinzusetzen und seine steuererklärung
sofort dann endlich fertig zu machen
ich möchte mich es war mein erstes
gesetz was ich wirklich als
berichterstatterin begleitet habe und es
hat mir richtig viel freude bereite ich
mich auch an dieser stelle einmal
persönlich bedanken bei der
parlamentarischen staatssekretärin
hessel mit der wir den dialog waren bei
markus herbrand maximilian motors bei
kazama wie bei den hof hausen bei
michael studie und natürlich bei meinen
gästen grünen die das alle wissen es war
mir eine große freude und dem ausblick
final die degressive afa es ist sehr gut
wir handeln pragmatisch wir handeln
schnell als regierung aber wir haben uns
auch verankert in zukunft werden wir den
begriff steuern steuern auch nochmal
weiterentwickeln in bezug auf
zukunftsfähigkeit und investitionen in
klimaschutz in digitalisierung noch
besser anreizen und auch da freue ich
mich sehr auf den prozess das klug und
zukunftsweisend hinzubekommen herzlichen
dank ein gutes gesetz ich freue mich auf
die zustimmung
katharina beck grades für die grünen und
liebt sie auch gesagt ziemlich viele
tolle dinge würden da drinstehen und ich
kann nochmal aufgreifen was sie erwähnt
hat der finanzausschuss der hat nochmals
nachgebessert einem regierungsentwurf
nämlich geplanten vorschriften zur
steuerfreien auszahlung ist pflege bonus
sind noch mal verbessert worden
wurde über den pflege bonus oder über
die sonderzahlung geredet viel zu lange
wurde geklatscht statt zu zahlen und
auch verzeihen sie mir frau kollegin weg
damit ich ihre harmonie ein bisschen
hier nicht störe diese
koalitionsinterne fingerhakler dem
zusammenhang über welche bereiche wir
bei der steuerfreiheit hier reden war
doch bezeichnend genau dafür und ich
möchte auch die gelegenheit nutzen den
pflegerinnen und pfleger meinen höchsten
respekt zollen denn sie waren es die uns
durch diese pandemie geführt haben denn
sie waren und sind das rückgrat in
unserem gesundheitssystem und das
mindeste meine damen und herren sehr
geehrter magie ist dass er jetzt gott
sei dank noch die kurve bekommen haben
und den empfängerkreis ausgeweitet haben
aber wir plädieren als linke auch für
einen deutlich höheren bonus einer der
auf die besonderen leistungen der pflege
auch wirklich gerecht wird erst recht
vor dem hintergrund der explodierenden
preise die wir alle feststellen und
diese upsons zählerei der letzten wochen
und monate war nicht nur respektlos
sondern sie hat auch noch den fehlenden
pflegerinnen und pflegern auch noch viel
geld gekostet und meine damen und herren
die links fraktion begrüßt natürlich die
home office pauschale und dass sie
verlängert wird auch bis zum
31.12 aber liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der koalition alle fakten für
eine verlängerung liegen auf dem tisch
da müssen wir doch nicht noch meine ehre
runde drehen stichwort kurzarbeitergeld
auch hier eine ganz klare zustimmung der
linken zum grundsatz dass das
kurzarbeitergeld steuerfrei gestellt
wird gleichzeitig enttäuscht sind wir
natürlich ist auch im vierten anlauf bei
diesem corona steuer hilfe gesetz den
progressionsvorbehalt
beim kurzarbeitergeld nicht abschaffen
typischer politik spreche
progressionsvorbehalt verstehen die
menschen in meinem wahlkreis in der
lausitz möglicherweise nicht dass wir
hier kurz erklärt er nur das
kurzarbeitergeld ist steuerfrei aber zur
ermittlung des einkommens steuersatzes
wird das auch das reguläre einkommen
angerechnet so dass die kurzarbeiter
höhere steuertarife möglicherweise zu
befürchten die folge ist lang sie eine
zwischenfrage der kollegin beck ja gerne
ich war grad noch beim thema
fingerhakeleien und wollte an dieser
stelle irgendwie in eine frage verpacken
dass ich mich sehr aber gefreut habe
dass auch sie gestern der ausweitung der
bonuszahlung und der steuerfreiheit
zugestimmt haben das fand ich sehr schön
das haben übrigens alle fraktionen dem
zugestimmt und deswegen als frage
irgendwie verpackt hier an der stelle
noch mal die frage warum sie da jetzt so
kritisch darauf eingehen vielleicht wenn
sie dem doch zugestimmt haben
[Applaus]
natürlich haben wir diese auswertung
dazu gestimmt aber sie haben als
koalition im zusammenhang mit die pflege
bonus und der steuerfreiheit glaube ich
als allererster maßnahme hier im
november des letzten jahres also vor
fast sieben monaten diesen pflege bonus
und die steuerfreiheit thematisiert und
die zeit die sie gebraucht haben für
diese maßnahmen ist einfach zu lang vor
dem hintergrund dass die menschen die
uns hier durch die krise getragen habe
entsprechend honoriert werden und das
wollte ich deutlich machen
aber nochmal zum kurzarbeitergeld zurück
herr präsident vielen dank
ich war bei dem bei der post vom
finanzamt und am ende steht natürlich
dann auch eine saftige nachzahlung
möglicherweise bei dem ein oder anderen
die ohnehin schon in der korona krise
viele entbehrungen hinnehmen musste und
auch einkommensverluste hinnehmen
mussten und viele rechnen und auch gar
nicht damit und da bin ich dann auch
schon beim rechnen zumindest für den
bundeshaushalt hat dass sich gerechnet
dass ungefähr 3,4 milliarden euro
einnahmen durch die progression im
bundeshaushalt dann über den rückweg
gelandet sind ich finde das ist nicht in
ordnung das ist auch eine
unverschämtheit und die leute kommen
sich auf verschaukelt vor auf der einen
seite haben wir die
exorbitanten gewinne der energiekonzerne
auf der anderen seite müssen diese
menschen die in kurzarbeit waren auf
steuerzahlungen möglicherweise warten
und das hat meine damen und herren mit
respekt das hat auch mit fortschritt und
das hat auch nichts mit gerechtigkeit zu
tun und insofern meine forderung und
gebiete entlasten sie die kurzarbeiter-
und steuern sie endlich diese
krisengewinner und sie haben morgen die
möglichkeit bei uns im antrag über die
über gewinnt steuer genau dazu zurück
vielen dank herr könig lücke
als nächstes erhält das deutschen
kollegen maximilian mordhorst
ja sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich glaube wäre
der debatte auch nur halbwegs aufmerksam
gefolgt ist sieht es besteht hier eine
große einigkeit in bezug auf dieses
vierter coroner steuer hilfe gesetz und
das ist ja geht bis auf eine zu mir
zumindest sehr lang vorkommen der krude
eu vorlesung gab es nicht mal von der
linken eine grundsatzkritik an dem was
wir hier machen als sie können sich
sicher sein wenn wir eine so breite
mehrheit dieses hauses haben dann kann
man glaube ich abschließend sagen dass
kroner steuer hilfe gesetz es ist sehr
gut und deswegen kann man ihn mit gutem
gewissen auch zustimmt ich will deswegen
gar nicht so viel schwerer und eurer
zeit in anspruch nehmen möchte auch noch
auf das ein oder andere eingehen was die
union ja teilweise von uns abgeschrieben
hat was mir aber doch ein bisschen sorge
bereitet ist und das glaube ich sollten
wir uns schon merken vielleicht noch als
ergänzung zu den bisher genannten
punkten wir beschließen hier ein crooner
corona steuer hilfe gesetzt und dass sie
da maßnahmen vorschlagen viele davon
sind ausnahmen ich würde mich freuen
wenn wir das eine oder andere auch
verlängern aber dass sie hier maßnahmen
vorschlagen beispielsweise bei den
steuerberater fristen die bis 2029
laufen sollen also ich den optimismus
sollten wir uns schon zutrauen dass wir
solche sondergesetze dann nicht mehr
brauchen dass wir da vernünftige
änderungen hinbekommen gerne aber solche
ausnahme lösungen beim corona steuer
hilfe gesetz glaube ich die sind da
gerade feilt untergebracht ist passt
aber zu dem steuerpolitischen potpourri
dass man in ihrem antrag so ein bisschen
sieht alles was man in den letzten 16
jahren nicht gemacht hat packt man jetzt
mal so ein bisschen zusammen und
versucht es durchzusetzen ich glaube wir
haben in den letzten 9 58 monaten schon
eine ganze menge auf den weg gebracht
wir werden das weiter machen und
deswegen kann ich nur darum bitten
stimmen sie dem vierten corona steuer
hilfe gesetz zu es ist sehr gut
das kann ja mal eine ordentlich kurze
rede im nächster redner ist der belege
sebastian brehm cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wir haben ja schon in unserer zeit als
bundesregierung in der damaligen großen
koalition die korona steuer hilfe
gesetze 1 2 und 3 auf den weg gebracht
mit wichtigen maßnahmen
kurzarbeitergeld überbrückungshilfen die
möglichkeit der inanspruchnahme von kfw
krediten und vielen vielen anderen
maßnahmen und wir haben damit mit diesen
gesetzen in der pandemie der wirtschaft
unter die arme gegriffen und
stabilisiert deshalb wenn man das
rückwirkend auch betrachtet muss man
sagen es ist gelungen die
insolvenzquote war so niedrig wie noch
nie wir konnten arbeitslosigkeit
verhindern und die betriebe wieder in
die zukunft führen auch die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmern
deswegen ist das vierte corona steuer
hilfe gesetz auch konsequent und setzt
die maßnahme die wir damals mit
aufgesetzt haben ford und deswegen
stimmen wir diesem gesetz auch zu über
kollegin mordhorst ob das ein sehr gutes
gesetzes das weiß ich jetzt nicht da
fehlen natürlich noch wesentliche
inhalte die sie übrigens immer selber
auch beantragt haben mich kommen dann
später noch mal drauf aber wenn
natürlich konsequenterweise die
maßnahmen fortgeführt werden die wir
auch beschlossen haben dann ist es eben
auch richtig diesem gesetz zuzustimmen
aber unsere aufgabe liebe kolleginnen
kollegen de unsere aufgabe als
opposition ist es gute anträge zu
unterstützen aber auch den finger in die
wunde zu legen wenn noch dinge fielen
deswegen haben wir unsere
entschließungsantrag auf den weg
gebracht weil wir glaube ich deutlich
ansprechen müssen was in diesem gesetz
fehlt also erstens die steuerfreie
zuschüsse zum kurzarbeitergeld werden um
sechs monate verlängert konsequent und
richtig haben wir auch damals mit
angestoßen bei der home office pauschale
piccoli und kollegen da muss ich ein
bisschen schmunzeln
es ist ein ureigenes thema der csu
gewesen die home office pauschale
sozusagen auf den weg zu bringen was wir
der diskussionen geführt haben die
überhaupt durchzubekommen bei den
kolleginnen und kollegen der spd es war
ja wahnsinn in dem gesetz und jetzt
verlängern sie es und schreibens auf
ihre fahne aber ich bin ja dankbar dafür
dass sie es tun und ich bin gespannt
übrigens auf die vorschläge die da
kommen zu einer erweiterung der home
office pauschale und eine verstetigung
wir hätten uns vorstellen können dass
wir die verstetigung auch jetzt schon in
diesem gesetzentwurf 10
die möglichkeit der inanspruchnahme
degressive abschreibung ist in ordnung
und ist richtig auch hier hätte man eine
entfristung vornehmen können aber gut es
ist ein wichtiger und richtiger schritt
die fristen zur abgabe der
steuererklärungen beratenen fällen auch
da haben sie zunächst in ihrem
gesetzentwurf eine verkürzung dieser
fristen vorgenommen sie haben das
zurückgeführt ist ab schmelz modell was
sie gesagt haben aber gerade in einer
zeit in der die steuer künstler ein
extreme belastungen haben extreme
belastungen haben krone hilfen
beantragen die schlussrechnung der
korona hilfen die grundsteuer
beantragung juli bis oktober muss eine
erklärungsfrist verlängert werden und
sie haben fast eins zu eins
dankenswerterweise unserer intervention
wahrgenommen unseren antrag umgesetzt
danke dafür dass sie das getan haben
die verlängerung der investitions
fristen ist folgerichtig im
einkommensteuerrecht für investitions
abzugsbeträge usw
bei der verlustverrechnung da will ich
schon noch mal drauf zu verstetigen den
zweijährigen verlust drückt tags
zeitraum aber genau jetzt ist es
handwerklich falsch sie haben ja selber
in der letzten periode anträge gestellt
vier jahre rückt raack die fdp hat mal
drei jahre rücktritt gefordert wenn wir
jetzt verlust rück träge machen vom jahr
2022 in das jahr 2020 dann tragen wir in
ein jahr zurück oder in zwei jahre
zurück die von der pandemie betroffen
waren es hat also null effekt weil 2020
waren bei vielen verlustjahre und sie
tragen jetzt in den verlust zurück wenn
hätten sie ihre antrag ernst nehmen
müssen und auf drei jahre als in das
gewinn jahr 2019 noch mit zurück tragen
müssen das wäre konsequent gewesen
deswegen haben wir es noch mal beantragt
und wenn wir auch mal guten antrag
stellen könnten sie ja auch zustimmen
aber vielleicht bleiben sie da in der
parteipolitischen brille und sagen
machen wir nicht also jetzt wäre es
möglich wir haben sie heute beantragt
sie könnten eigentlich zustimmen tun sie
aber nicht
und ich will noch auf 1 zu sprechen
kommen natürlich im pflegebereich auch
da haben sie gott sei dank noch mal
nachgeschärft weil viele
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter in
ihrem ersten entwurf ausgenommen waren
wir hatten zahlreiche anfragen warum wir
nicht wir sind doch auch im bereich der
pflege tätig wir haben da in der
diskussion des noch erreicht gemeinsam
diesen kreis der berechtigten für den
corona bonus oder für den pflege bonus
auszuweiten das ist richtig aber eine
berufsgruppe das ist glaube ich auch in
der anhörung
zu tragen kommen eine berufs probieren
sie sprechen von respekt liebe kollegin
beck und von wertschätzung eine
berufsgruppe er findet überhaupt nicht
ihre wertschätzung das sind die über
500.000 steuerfachangestellten und
steuerfachwirt die in den kanzleien
arbeiten die extrem belastet sind in
dieser zeit und wir hätten uns gewünscht
dass sie zumindest hier die korona
prämie auch ausweiten aber
wahrscheinlich mögen sie diese
berufsgruppe nicht und deswegen haben
sie es ihre ausgenommen ähnlich wie beim
klima geld nehmen sie einfach
wesentliche teile aus dem gesetz raus
schade dass sie hier keinen respekt
zollen und
es fehlen natürlich wichtige dinge
deswegen haben wir auch ergänzend
unseren antrag gestellt
abschaffung solidaritätszuschlag sie
klagen ja sogar für die abschaffung des
solidaritätszuschlags hätten sie rein
bringen können jetzt sitzen sie am
steuer und das was sie beklagen setzten
sich um turbo abschreibung kündigen sie
an machen sie nicht und die anpassung
des 1 und die tarife werden ja heute
nachmittag noch mal drüber reden tun sie
auch nicht in dem maße wie es notwendig
ist also deswegen kein sehr gutes gesetz
sind wichtige punkte dabei den wir
zustimmen aber sie hätten deutlich mehr
machen können herzlichen dank nun sagt
sebastian brehm war das für die
unionsfraktion mitglied im
finanzausschuss dort ist das ganze jahr
vor allem behandelt worden und
wir hören jetzt für die spd nadine
heselhaus
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren das vierte corona steuer hilfe
gesetz steht in einer reihe von hilfen
die die finanziellen auswirkungen der
pandemie auf die menschen in deutschland
verringern bürgerinnen und bürger und
unternehmen erfahren steuerliche
entlastungen dabei muss man ehrlich
zugeben dass der staat hätten nie
vollständig ausgleichen kann auch die
der pandemie nicht wir mildern die
belastungen für die bevölkerung ab dabei
haben wir alle menschen im blick
insbesondere jene mit niedrigem
einkommen
[Musik]
die arbeitsbelastung wurde in vorherigen
reden bereits angesprochen insbesondere
im gesundheitswesen ist diese
außerordentlich hoch die wertschätzung
für die arbeit der pflegekräfte und
anderer gruppen stieg in der letzten
zeit deutlich an vielen menschen wurde
noch einmal bewusst welchen stellenwert
die arbeit im gesundheitsbereich für
unsere gesellschaft hat uns ist es
wichtig diese herausragende leistung und
der einsatz nicht nur öffentliche
wertschätzung
dass diese herausragende leistung und
der einsatz nicht nur öffentliche
wertschätzung erfahren sondern sich auch
im geldbeutel widerspiegeln wir arbeiten
langfristig an besseren löhnen und
arbeitsbedingungen weil nur tariflöhne
eine ordentliche bezahlung garantieren
und darüber hinaus muss der besondere
einsatz der letzten zeit auch besonders
entlohnt werden können deshalb haben wir
uns für einen pflege bonus in höhe von
insgesamt einer milliarde euro
eingesetzt und damit der bonus auch im
portemonnaie ankommt stellen wir jetzt
zahlungen bis zu 4500 euro steuerfrei
die steuerpflichtigen insgesamt und auch
die steuerberatenden berufe sind durch
die andauernde corona pandemie weiterhin
belastet diesbezüglich haben wir in den
vergangenen jahren die steuerlichen
abgabefristen immer wieder verlängert
und so auch für zeitliche entlastung
gesorgt
schon jetzt können wir damit rechnen
dass es in den kanzleien durch die
bearbeitung der krone helfen und der
grundsteuer zu mehrbelastungen in den
folgenden jahren kommen wird daher
erweitern wir die frist für das
steuerjahr
2020 und denen diese auch abgestuft für
die kommenden jahre aus die
verlängerungen werden dann schrittweise
zurückgeführt so dass ab dem
besteuerungs zeitraum 2025 wieder die
regulären termine und fristen für
beratende fälle zur anwendung kommen
werden auch diejenigen die ihre
steuererklärung selbst erstellen
erhalten verlängerte abgabefristen für
die steuerjahre des 2023 mit dieser
vorausschauenden regelung der
abgabefristen schaffen wir
planungssicherheit für steuerpflichtige
für die kanzleien und auch für die
verwaltung
das vierte coroner steuer hilfe gesetz
enthält darüber hinaus eine reihe von
maßnahmen die arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer im besonderen unterstützen
von der steuerlichen förderung der
zuschüsse zum kurzarbeitergeld bis hin
zu home office pauschale in der korona
pandemie arbeiten viele
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer und
auch viele selbstständige im home office
oft fehlen dabei die voraussetzungen für
ein häusliches arbeitszimmer viele
arbeiten in einer arbeitsecke am küchen
oder eben auch am esstisch um auch
diesen erwerbstätigen einen steuerlichen
abzug zu ermöglichen hat die vorherige
regierung und insbesondere hubertus heil
eine home office pauschale eingeführt
so kann auch wenn es kein echtes aber
das thema hat
bis zu 600 euro im jahr als
werbungskosten geltend machen
diese gut angenommene maßnahme
verlängern wir auch für das jahr
wir sehen dass viele menschen immer mehr
geld für das nötigste ausgeben müssen
darauf hat die bundesregierung reagiert
und zwei entlastungs paket in höhe von
fast 30 milliarden euro beschlossen
dieses vierte corona steuer hilfe gesetz
kommt noch dazu denn entlastung muss in
diesen tagen breit angelegt sein
als nächstes internet hält das wort
kollegin dr sandra letzter wird sich die
guten
sehr verehrte präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wir haben dieses gesetz vorgelegt und da
hatte meine vorrednerin jetzt gerade das
richtige gesagt dazu in der hoffnung
unternehmern und den menschen
unterstützung zukommen zu lassen und die
negativen wirtschaftlichen folgen der
krise abzufedern aber natürlich sind wir
uns sehr bewusst dass wir die kompletten
folgen natürlich nicht abfedern können
und deswegen danke ich all denjenigen
die verständnis auch dafür haben dass
wir als gesetzgeber eben nicht alles
auffangen können was an harten auf
trifft das bringt viele an den die
leistungsfähigkeit an die ende ihrer
kräfte und wenn sie da einfach ein ganz
klein bisschen nachsehen mit uns haben
wir uns das sehr sehr lieb und dafür
möchte ich mich herzlich bedanken
kolleginnen und kollegen haben die ganze
vielzahl der maßnahmen auch schon
aufgezählt wir auf den weg gebracht
haben und ich will einen zweiten
gedanken da vielleicht eher zufügen
insbesondere natürlich bei der
unterstützung von unternehmen die wir
jetzt hier vornehmen ist die
verlängerung der degressiven
abschreibung die verlängerung der
investitions fristen auf die dauerhafte
ausweitung des zeitraums für den verlust
zurücktrat natürlich ganz entscheidend
und ja die kollegin weg hat es ja schon
gesagt beim verlust rück tag hätten wir
uns grüne auch gerade im kontext der
pandemie noch einmal verlängerte
rücktritt zurück tags fürsten vorstellen
können was die kollegen von der cdu
sagen sind ja das ja ganz genau richtig
wir sind natürlich in der situation dass
wir jetzt mit den rückt regen genau in
die pandemie jahre kommen das wissen wir
auch allerdings allerdings jetzt ist der
punkt der nächste nicht machen will wir
haben natürlich in der situation schon
auch immer das gesamtbild im blick zu
halten und wir müssen sehen dass die das
meer sozusagen an steht das jetzt die
unternehmen gerade dann durch den
verlust rückgrat bekommen natürlich
schon auch ein weniger an liquidität für
die öffentlichen haushalte bedeutet also
dass bund länder und kommunen daran
stückchen weit in vorleistung gehen auch
für die liquidität und ich glaube wir
dürfen klage die länder und die kommunen
deren haushalte ja auch von den corona
folgen gezeichnet sind da eben nicht
überlasten und ich glaube deswegen macht
eben genau dieser zeitraum von zwei
jahren den wir gewählt haben sind und es
ist ein guter kompromiss
und jetzt will ich zu ende noch einen
gedanken loswerden denn heute sind ja
wirklich viele berufsgruppen zurecht
gemacht worden und ich will ganz
besonders jetzt einer danken das sind
die beschäftigten in den
steuerverwaltungen denn wir wissen
natürlich ganz genau dass sie in den
finanzämtern das rückgrat einfach des
deutschen staates sind und dass ihre
gute arbeit die staatlichen einnahmen
und ja auch die steuer gerechtigkeit in
diesem land sicherte und natürlich ist
jetzt die steuerverwaltung
wissen sie meine verehrten kolleginnen
sache der länder und dennoch ist uns
grünen natürlich sehr sehr bewusst dass
wir mit diesem controller steuer hilfe
gesetze noch einmal zusätzliche
belastungen auch für die verwaltung
schaffen und es sind mehr aufgaben die
erstmal zu stemmen sind deswegen an
dieser stelle nochmal herzlichen dank an
die beschäftigten in den finanzämtern
sie sind es die dieses vierte cola
steuer hilfe gesetz zum erfolg machen
herzlichen dank
vielen dank das sagt sandra des örv für
bündnis 90/die grünen und ein weiteres
mitglied im finanzausschuss ist wohlauf
coating er spricht jetzt für die union
präsident werde kolleginnen und kollegen
vor 40 tagen haben wir hier das vierte
corona steuer hilfe gesetz zum ersten
mal debattiert und besprochen und schon
da habe ich sehr deutlich gemacht dass
die fortführung bewährter steuerliche
maßnahmen in der krisenzeit durchaus ein
probates mittel ist um
unkompliziert hilfen zur verfügung zu
stellen für die menschen für die
unternehmen die von der krise betroffen
sind aber und das ist entscheidend
mit den jetzt vorgesehenen
minimalinvasiven korrekturen bei diesem
gesetz können sie von der andere das von
ihnen gesteckte ziel nicht erreichen
denn das gesteckte ziel war ja die
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen
einschränkungen durch die korona
pandemie so gering wie auch immer
möglich zu halten und es reicht deswegen
nicht was hier vorliegt weil es
mittlerweile ja nicht mehr nur alleine
um die folgen der korona krise geht
sondern es geht um die wirtschaftlichen
konsequenzen des unsäglichen
angriffskrieges von russland auf die
ukraine es geht um die rapide steigende
inflation und die muss die
bundesregierung entschlossen bekämpfen
und das insbesondere deswegen weil da
steht uns so hat das größte noch bevor
ja sie haben in der tat schon mehrere
gesetzentwürfe vorgelegt das geht ja
nicht nur hier um dieses einzige gesetz
aber all diesen gesetzen die hier in den
letzten wochen vorgelegt werden
haben eines gemeinsam es sind zwar gute
ansätze enthalten aber es wird überall
zu kurz gesprungen
da werden maßnahmen des zweiten corner
steuer hilfe gesetzes wie die
verlängerung von verlust
verrechnungsmöglichkeiten oder die
degressiven abschreibung für bewegliche
wirtschaftsgüter und auch die
steuerlichen investitions fristen
verlängert aber man muss sich doch
fragen ob diese maßnahmen tatsächlich in
der praxis den unternehmen entsprechend
helfen und vor allem mittelständische
unternehmen müssen doch erstmal in die
lage versetzt werden verlustfrei zu
wirtschaften und in die zukunft zu
investieren und dazu brauchen wir stark
verbesserte wirtschaftspolitische und
steuerliche rahmenbedingungen
um endlich da jetzt in dieser
krisensituation auch die
rahmenbedingungen zu schaffen und das
muss die bundesregierung eben jetzt
umsetzen und nicht erst in einigen
monaten oder in jahren ankündigungen
jedenfalls und markige sprüche reichen
hier nicht sondern wir brauchen jetzt
taten nur dann wird wieder in die
zukunft investiert deswegen liebe ampel
stärken sie die eigenkapitalbasis der
betriebe passen sie die behandlung von
gewinnen die zur stärkung der
eigenkapitalbasis unternehmen
einbehalten werden der jetzigen
situation an die thesaurierung
begünstigung die muss praktikabler
werden sie muss praktisch
praxistauglicher und attraktiver gerade
auch für kleine und mittlere unternehmen
gemacht werden
und in dieser situation
das haben wir jetzt schon mehrfach hier
gehört muss auch der ertrags steuerliche
verlust rück trotz
zurücktrat zeitraum auf mindestens drei
jahre erhöht wird gerade jetzt wo es um
die krisenjahre 20 21 22 geht dann macht
es doch keinen sinn und kollege bremen
wollen schon mal deutlich gemacht wir
können doch nicht in corona verlustjahr
mit dem corona verlustjahr verrechnen
das macht er nun überhaupt keinen sinn
deswegen muss das dauerhaft ausgeweitet
werden und wir haben das ja auch
entsprechend beantragt
und was eben auch fehlt in diesem gesetz
ist das thema wie gehen wir damit um
dass die betriebe die in russland und in
der kranken kleine investiert sind jetzt
von sanktionen enteignungen zerstörungen
betroffen sind die dortigen
beteiligungen deutscher
steuerpflichtiger die müssen auch
entsprechend jetzt berücksichtigt werden
da brauchen wir temporär steuerliche
abschreibungen das muss einfach hier in
so ein gesetz in der aktuellen situation
mit aufgenommen
sie habe in den beratungen in den
letzten vierzig tagen bei diesem
gesetzgebungsverfahren leider nur wenig
bewegt eine kleine verbesserung nämlich
die verlängerung der
steuererklärungspflicht die haben sie
hinbekommen das finden wir auch gut das
ist gelungen durch den druck der cdu csu
fraktion aber auch der bundesländer des
bundesrates und das sind das ist gut
ausdrücklich finden wir das richtig und
gut meine grundsätzliche unterstützung
gilt im übrigen auch allen regelungen
die den arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmern zugute kommen die
angesprochene fristen verlängerung die
förderung des feuer steuerfreien
zuschuss beim kurzarbeitergeld
die verlängerung bei der hauptbau schale
alles richtig alles gut aber warum
entfristen sie es da nicht warum immer
nur eine kurzfristige verlängerung eine
entfristung wäre hier besser ist wäre
das richtige signal für arbeitnehmer und
für die unternehmen
und auch die hier schon angesprochenen
bonuszahlungen da können wir
selbstverständlich den vorgenommenen
änderungen zustimmen
ich glaube es macht sinn dass wir die
leistungen der beschäftigten im
gesundheits und pflegebereich hier
honorieren aber eins muss man auch noch
mal unterstreichen das ist keine
automatische auszahlung die hier
vorgenommen wird es wird ja immer so der
eindruck erweckt als ob das schon sicher
wäre es gehört auch hier noch der
arbeitgeber dazu der das entsprechend
auszahlen muss und dieser wunsch zur
eingrenzung dann kann ich auch verstehen
ja wohl natürlich hier nicht mehr den
gleichen fehler machen wie bei den bonus
aus der ersten pole regelung dass die
mitglieder des bundesvorstands der
grünen sich da bedienen sollen natürlich
nicht mehr vorkommen deswegen diese
einschränkung ist richtig
einsatzbedingungen
ich kann diesen gesetzentwurf zustimmen
das hatten wir schon angekündigt hält
aber ich werde gleichzeitig auch um
zustimmung für unseren
entschließungsantrag mut zu wesentlichen
steuerlichen hilfsmaßnahmen dieser
erhält richtig und steuerlichen hat soll
jetzt auch in winzigen jetzt das wort
ist jetzt wird sie gar nicht gut
da der bundestags- vizepräsident
wolfgang kubicki der achtet auf die
redezeiten die debatten haben ja alle
vom ältestenrat festgelegte debatten
zeit die fraktionen teilen dann ihrer
größe entsprechend den verschiedenen
rednern
minuten rede minuten zu und der
bundestagsvizepräsident wolfgang kubicki
hat natürlich auch jeden tagesordnung
heute im blick die noch bis mitternacht
klick meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
von der union und auch im sonstigen saal
bei der bewältigung der korona pandemie
ist unser oberstes ziel seit jahren
gewesen die wirtschaftlichen und die
sozialen belange so gering wie möglich
zu belasten
daher sieht das heute zu beschließende
gesetz über steuerliche maßnahmen
zugunsten von bürgerinnen und bürger und
unternehmen eine ganze menge von
maßnahmen vor ich werde da auch gleich
noch drauf eingehen da aber die
kolleginnen und kollegen der union jetzt
so häufig ihren entschließungsantrag mut
zu wesentlichen steuerlichen
hilfsmaßnahmen also er hört sich ja sehr
staatstragend kann aber er ist jetzt
wirklich auch ziemlich dünn das sind
gerade mal zwölf forderungen da drin
hier so hoch loben will ich dann doch
auch da etwas drauf eingehen im grunde
genommen ist ihr antrag nichts an als
ein
steuerpolitisches sammelsurium oder ein
steuerpolitisches kraut und rüben ein
durcheinander von forderungen die sie
immer mal wieder gestellt haben aber nie
selber haben durchsetzen können
man kann man kann natürlich auch sagen
es handelt sich um einen klientel antrag
ein klientel ertragen wie nicht anders
zu erwarten
adressieren sie vor allen dingen
unternehmen an die arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer denken sie da mit ihren
vorschlägen ja weniger jedenfalls drei
viertel drei viertel bot ihm an ihrer
vorschläge beziehen sich ausschließlich
auf die unternehmensbesteuerung in
diesem antrag wenn man sich genau
anguckt und wenn man sich ernsthaft dann
inhaltlich mit dem einzelnen forderungen
auch noch beschäftigen möchte dann kommt
man natürlich auch zu der frage wie soll
das denn tatsächlich finanziert werden
sie müssen ja nicht nur vorschläge
machen sondern sie müssen sie auch
irgendwie gegenfinanziert denn immerhin
würden ihre vorschläge im bundeshaushalt
einige milliarden geringere einnahmen
produzieren
gegenfinanzierung in ihrem antrag
fehlanzeige zur finanzierung ihrer
großzügigen steuergeschenke findet man
dann lediglich den halbsatz die
maßnahmen soll ich zitiere im rahmen der
verfügbaren haushaltsmittel zitat ende
durch die bundesregierung umgesetzt
werden ja echt jetzt liebe union was
bedeutet das denn ganz konkret das
bedeutet sie haben sich noch nicht
einmal die mühe gemacht ihre eigenen
vorschläge durchzurechnen und
gegenzufinanzieren also ziemlich dünn
was davor liegt
ich freue mich das haben sie am anfang
auch gesagt dass sie schlussendlich doch
noch überzeugt wurden und dem
gesetzentwurf des corona steuer hilfe
gesetzes zustimmen würden werden ihr
antrag ist natürlich da nicht besonders
förderlich wir dagegen kümmert uns um
die menschen und um die unternehmen in
unserem land sie sind uns eben nicht
egal und deshalb haben wir auch mit den
beiden entlastungs paketen die wir in
den vergangenen wochen ja schon
besprochen haben zahlreiche entlastungen
und auch mit diesem corona steuer hilfe
gesetz auf den weg gebracht die sowohl
für die menschen für die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
wichtig sind und auch für die
unternehmen und das ist gute
fortschrittliche politik meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren denn ich will
das mal ganz kurz und komprimiert noch
zusammenfassen die maßnahmen die wir in
dem entsprechenden
steuerentlastungsgesetz durchgesetzt
haben anhebung grundfreibetrag anregung
arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag vorziehen der
befristeten anhebung der
entfernungspauschale für fernpendler
energiepreis pauschale kinderbonus durch
diesen bereits verabschiedeten
entlastungspaket werden die bürgerinnen
und bürger insgesamt sich um 16
milliarden euro entlastet das ist auch
nicht nichts dafür muss man sich auch
nicht entschuldigt das ist gut und
richtig dass wir so beschlossen haben
gerade darauf hingewiesen dass sie sich
nicht entschuldigen müssen für
entlastungen würden sie sich bereit
erklären sich bei rentnerinnen und
rentnern und bafög empfängern zu
entschuldigen dass sie die mit den
kosten alleine sitzen gelassen haben
sehr geehrte frau kollegin hinweis auf
die entweder rentner profitieren
natürlich von dem entlastungspaket auch
sie werden das neun euro ticket nutzen
können auch sie kriegen die
heizkostenpauschale wenn sie wohngeld
empfängerinnen und empfänger sind auch
sie bekommen zum beispiel die energie
stoffe die eeg-umlage senkung wird es
sind ausreichende entlastung für alle
menschen in diesem paket enthalten
aber also das steuerentlastungspaket
vorteil man ist ja auch nicht alles
deshalb bringen wir ja heute auch
weitere steuerliche maßnahmen auf den
weg für die arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer ohne sonderzahlungen werden
bis zu 4500 euro steuerfrei und bei der
grundsicherung von arbeitssuchenden
nicht angerechnet hier verlängern die
home profis pauschale wie bereits schon
sehr umfassend ausgeführt wurde wir
verlängern die steuerfreiheit beim
kurzarbeitergeld die wirtschaftliche
erholung führt durch zusätzliche
investitionen und investitionsanreize
für unternehmen unterstützt dazu
verbessern wir die möglichkeiten der
verlustverrechnung die degressive
abschreibung für bewegliche
wirtschaftsgüter des anlagevermögens
vermögens wird verlängert und
steuerliche investitions fristen
ausgeweitet und zur steuerbefreiung des
pflege bonus hat ja auch mein kollege
armani entsprechend ausgeführt meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der union als
opposition kann man ja immer mal ein
bisschen knapper und sagen es ist luft
nach oben und da muss noch mehr kommen
aber im grunde des herzens wissen sie
ganz genau diese regierung tut den
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmern und
den unternehmen gut und deshalb werden
wir auch diesen gesetzentwurf zustimmen
mit ihnen gemeinsam
[Applaus]
frauke heiligenstadt war das für die
spd-fraktion und jetzt hören wir viel
grün sagt weishaupt
präsident liebe kollegin in meiner
letzten rede habe ich davon gesprochen
dass es auch berufsgruppen gibt die eben
nicht vom pflege bonus gesetz
profitieren werden die aber letztendlich
alles dafür getan haben dass wir gut
durch die pandemie kommen und immer noch
gut durch diese partie gehen werden
darunter fallen die vielen vielen
medizinischen fachangestellten die neben
den normalen praxisalltag teils tausende
impfungen durchgeführt und organisiert
haben aber auch immer die erste
anlaufstelle waren für die vielen corona
patientinnen und das mit der ständigen
angst sich selber zu infizieren und das
mit ihnen ihre familie diese infektion
zu schleppen und in ihrem freundeskreis
aber es sind nicht nur die medizinischen
fachangestellten
es sind auch die rettungssanitäterin die
die erstversorgung gemanagt haben und
immer einem hohen infektionsrisiko
ausgesetzt sie haben ihnen besonders
schweren phasen in der pandemie mit
intensiv transporten eine größere
katastrophe und die vollständige
überlastung einzelner krankenhäuser
letztendlich verhindert und ehrlich
gesagt möchte ich diese zeit nehmen und
deswegen hören sie vielleicht auch noch
mal genauer zu wir müssen diesen
menschen danke sagen
aber kann er klar es kann ich bei
danksagungen bleiben sondern wir
erweitern deshalb nach grünen vorschlag
die steuerfreiheit für freiwillige boni
und wir schließen die beiden erwähnten
berufsgruppen mit einem noch viele
weitere berufsgruppen und arbeitnehmer
in in diversen einrichtungen
doch was bedeutet das konkret
letztendlich zum einen schaffen wir den
anderer hat sie beschäftigen für die
zusätzlichen belastung zu entlohnen und
zum anderen sind diese sonderleistungen
für die menschen die so viel geleistet
haben in der pandemie steuerfrei wenn
jetzt also beispielsweise eine ärztin
ihre mit irischen fachangestellten einen
bonus-teil möchte kommt dieser im vollem
maße auf dem konto der beschäftigten an
und das ist ein riesenerfolg
es ist ein klares signal an die vielen
beschäftigten dass sie ihre arbeit
wertschätzen sondern ist auch ein
zeichen an die berufsverbände und an die
menschen in der praxis die forderungen
und die stellungnahmen der
verschiedensten verbände sind unsere
arbeit mit eingeflossen und ist ein
zeichen dass die iren zu hören und sie
ernst nehmen
damit gehen wir wirklich den ersten
richtigen und wichtigen schritt in
richtung wertschätzung der
gesundheitsberufe
aber ehrlich gesagt und das wissen ja
alle dass kam ich schon sehr oft gesagt
dabei kann es nicht leiden mit abschrift
des gesetzes müssen wir uns neu
fokussieren wir müssen die
arbeitsbedingungen in den
gesundheitsberufen verbessern und für
mich bedeutet das wer konkret wir müssen
die berufs gesetze der gesundheitsberufe
modernisiert auch hier werden wir und
müssen wir mit den berufsverbänden
zusammen arbeiten ihnen zuhören und
antworten und lösungen finden für
drängende fragen
und ich bin mir sicher als antwort
koalition werden die richtige und
wichtige schritte gehen und diese berufs
gesetze ins 21 jahrhundert zu holen
vielen dank
[Applaus]
und einen redner haben wir noch hier
bevor dann über den gesetzentwurf zum
vierten cola steuer hilfe gesetz
abgestimmt wird
michaels rudi wird es dann für die spd
der finanzpolitische sprecher
präsident meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren ich habe mal angeschaut das erste
kroner steuerhinterzieher setzte april
2020 der hamburger weg gebracht die
steuerbefreiung zuschüsse arbeitgeber
zum kurzarbeitergeld machen weil setzen
wir fort wir sind es beim vierten
gewinner steuer hilfe gesetz angelangt
das sieht man die karte lesen nicht
vorbei die folgen sind nicht vorbei wir
müssen weiterhin etwas tun wir setzen
vieles von dem ford was wir angelegt
haben in der großen koalition wo vieles
richtig war woher den menschen und den
unternehmen geholfen haben ich glaube
nicht dass wir irgendwie sack und asche
gehen müssen dafür was wir tun sind
zwölf milliarden euro die wir auch mit
diesem gesetz auf den weg bringen wir
haben am anfang der letzten legislatur
noch um zwölf millionen vielleicht
bestritten jetzt hier zum 12 milliarden
das sind riesige pakete die hier auf den
weg bringen um die wirtschaft zu stützen
um den menschen zu helfen und ich glaube
das ist ein gutes signal mit dieser
ampelkoalition es wieder entsprechend
aufgeben und
und da darf man sich auch loben herr
künstler auch für die degressive afa
übrigens sind zehn milliarden euro die
wird da auf den weg bringen ich glaube
das kann man schon mal betonen dass wir
das tun dass oder andere weitere
maßnahme mit auf den weg bringen und was
wenn ich ganz gefällt auch bei der
zwischen frage von frau kümmern wir
fangen immer an einzelne maßnahmen sehr
isoliert für sich zu betrachten sagt
bahir mal da ein bisschen mehr und da
dort wenn ich mal zusammenfassen was
werden überbrückungshilfen kinder bundes
heizkostenzuschüsse kurzarbeitergeld
wirtschaft stabilisierungsfonds was wir
da alles auf den weg bringen dann kann
man nicht an der einen kleinen schraube
sagen da hätte man noch ein bisschen
mehr sonne das gesamtkonzept steht
übrigens auch bei einem klima
energiepreis pauschale und natürlich tun
wir was für rentner in renten natürlich
für studierende und ich glaube diese
gesamtschau muss man schon auch mal in
den blick nehmen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die schon besonderen
zwischenfrage aus der applikation ein
und wir tun auch was und das finde ich
auch wichtig zu betonen weil sich da
viel bei der union auch im bereich des
unternehmens steuerrechts befindet auch
für arbeitnehmerinnen arbeitnehmer und
her gut ding wenn sie das sagen es gab
nur minimal invasive eingriffe so ein
bisschen ein gesetzentwurf
eine million menschen arbeiten immerhin
arbeiten immer mehr die jetzt von der
steuerbefreiung des corona bonus
profitieren ist nicht minimalinvasiv
sondern gut gerecht und für die menschen
ein deutliches signal der wertschätzung
und pflegeberufen das muss man einmal
deutlich an der stelle sagen
richtig ist die unions fraktion stimmt
dort auch zu bewährtes fortsetzen von
dem was man richtig angelegt haben
das erkennbar auch an und ich glaube das
war auch ein gutes gespräch was wir noch
hatten in der in dieser woche war es
nochmal zum abschluss dieses gesetzes
aber natürlich in der opposition
scheint man immer noch ein stück weit
mehr drauf legen zu müssen das kommt mir
ein bisschen so vorher künstler haben
hamburger fischmarkt noch einmal hier
drauf und nochmal da so ich glaube so
funktioniert das ganze nicht ich weiß
noch ich komme mal nach hamburg zurück
machte schauen wir das sagen wie das
wird ist aber eher künstler ich kann
mich noch erinnern dass sie gesagt haben
zum thema der fristverlängerungen der
bundesrat hat auch vorschläge macht das
sei recht gut wir sind darüber hinaus
liegt da mal was anderes da kommen
natürlich auch gelobt davon dürfen union
noch mal eins drauf also ich glaube
müssen schauen was machbar was notwendig
ist und da haben wir auch mit jonas als
koalition getroffen dass sie dann mehr
und machen müssen als opposition ist
vielleicht in ordnung dass müssen was
sie mit sich vereinbaren aber wir machen
maße mir die gezielt sind die insgesamt
richtig sind die die richtigen treffen
und die in einem gewissen maße mitte
sind insofern sehr gutes gesetz ich
freue mich über die breite zustimmung
hier in diesem haus und würde wer über
eine wiederholung dieser großen
zustimmung bei anderen gesetzen auch
freundin dankeschön jetzt kommen wir zur
abstimmung über den gesetzentwurf unter
anderem zum vierten corona steuer hilfe
gesetzt hat eine kurzintervention
beantragt wie ich zulasse der kollege
stöbert das so
zunächst noch die fdp
wachsen
[Musik]
so verschicken dass hier wirklich
ausgewachsen einräumen dass die
maßnahmen vorgeschlagen werden bürgers
zielführend sind aber ich sage immer
heinz kennen sie die geschichte mit dem
feuerwehrmann erfolge hermann der massen
nach größe anzündet und hitler erhält
als erster preis und wird zu löschen
genau das ist das was wir machen sie
haben ganzen branche ein berufsverbot
und zwei jahre lang ausgesprochen sie
haben einzelhandel gastronomie hotel zu
geschlossen obwohl das nach dem ersten
knockout nicht mehr notwendig war jetzt
stellen sie sich hin und sagen wir
retten diese branchen ist doch um
verschiedene danke
aus silber von der fdp war das
tun ich muss das tun was ich muss eines
klar stellt ans herz gewachsen ist mir
meine frau meine kinder nicht die afd
zum einen
foto zweiten brandstifter ist ein virus
und putin und nicht wir und wir kämpfen
diese auswirkungen und das mit aller
kraft und zum wohle der menschen in der
bundesrepublik deutschland danke schön
so damit sind wir das ja hier am ende
der debatte willkommen zur abstimmung
tagesordnungspunkt 10 a wir kommen ins
abstimmung über den von der
bundesregierung eingebrachten
gesetzentwurf zur umsetzung steuerlicher
hilfsmaßnahmen zu der bildschirme die
bewohner krise der finanzausschuss
empfiehlt und der buchstabe a seiner
beschlussempfehlung auf drucksache 1906
den gesetzentwurf der bundesregierung
auf drucksachen
1111 und 1656 in der ausschluss fassung
anzunehmen ich will diejenigen die die
mindest entwurf in der ausschuss fassung
zustimmen wollen um das handzeichen
gegenprobe
[Musik]
enthaltungen dann ist der ganze wurf in
der ausstellung in zweiter lesung bei
enthaltung der fraktionen der afg unter
linken mit den stimmen der fraktionen
des hauses angenommen nun kommt meine
lieblings abstimmung dritte beratung und
schlussabstimmung ich bitte diejenigen
die dem gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen
sich zu erheben
danke schön wer stimmt dagegen
wer enthält sich
sehr schön dann ist dieser gesetzentwurf
in dritter lesung bei enthaltungen der
fraktionen der ard und der linke mit den
stimmen der fraktionen des hauses
angenommen ja mit einer kleinen
sportlichen einlage denn traditionell
ist es so dass bei der dritten lesung
hier die abgeordneten aufstehen müssen
das meinte wohl der
bundestags-vizepräsident also dieses
viertel corona steuer hilfe gesetz ist
hier mit der breiten mehrheit des hauses
verabschiedet worden das hatte sich ja
in der debatte angedeutet ein ganzes
bündel steuerliche maßnahmen dass bürger
und unternehmen weiter entlasten soll
die noch mit den folgen der krise
kämpfen es ist ja viel zu den einzelnen
punkten gesagt worden das gesetz dazu
vielleicht noch mal kurz ist ja noch mal
nachgebessert worden in den
ausschussberatungen
unter anderem soll ja der korona boni
für beschäftigte in der pflege
in krankenhäusern praxen bis zu einem
betrag von 4500 euro steuerfrei bleiben
da hatte man zuerst eine grenze von 3000
euro also das ist nochmal ausgeweitet
worden und auch der kreis der
anspruchsberechtigten
also tariflich und auf freiwillige boni
steuerfrei bleiben das ist nochmal
ausgeweitet worden